لاجل دعم ضحايا الزلزال شيف عمر الشهير
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الذي بات
نجما في عالم الطبخ دخل الى مناطق الشمال
السوري والجنوب التركي وذلك بهدف توزيع
المساعدات على الاهالي المتضررين من
الزلزال راغبا في تسليم المساعدات بنفسه
وباليد وهي عباره عن مواد طبيه بكميه جيده
بالاضافه الى المواد الغذائيه حيث سيتم
تسليم المواد الطبيه الى اداره المشافي
عبر مديريات الصحه التابعه لوزاره الصحه
في الحكومه المؤقته كما يروي لمتابعيه
المشهد الماساوي الذي خلفه الزلزال من ارض
الواقع لما دخلنا انطاكيا الساعه اربعه
الصبح ماشيين بالسياره يعني
ما عالم نائمه جسس على اليمين وعلى اليسار
ناحيه بنايات مغطينهم حرام طب شاف حرس
شخصيا على التوجه الى المناطق المتضرره
ميدانيا لتوزيع المساعدات على ضحايا
الزلزال حدثنا اكثر عن هذه التجربه وكيف
جاءتك الفكره
بصراحه اول يوم صار فيه زلزال قعدت تفكر
انه انا شو اعمل شو ساوي
حسيت رب العالمين الهمني انه انت فيك
تساوي كتير فيك تعمل كتير يعني انه انا ما
حطيتك بهذا المكان لحتى بس هيك تضل قاعد
تتفرج قررت انه انا انزل على
جنوب التركي على انطاكيا اكثر مكان فيه
سوريين نزلنا ضلينا تقريبا خمس ايام هنيكه
بعدها رجعنا لاسطنبول عبينا كمان التريلا
وشاحنات مواد غذائيه وكمان على الشمال
السوري حبيت اكون انا موجود مع الناس ليش
لحتى يكون في دعم معنوي قدر الامكان
يعني حاول قدر الامكان بس يعني يطلعون من
الشيء اللي هن فيه لو لحظه واحده
اعطيهم امل بالحياه اعطيهم انه هذا الشيء
حينتهي يعني هذا الشيء ما حيضل هيك
وانا كل كل حدا
هذا الوقت رح يمرق يعني هذا الوقت العصيب
رح يمرق ان شاء الله رح يمرق فحبيت تكون
معن يعني بكون في دعم معنوي اكثر يعني انت
عايش باسطنبول منذ سنوات
وخصوصا يعني لحظه وقوع الزلزال وبنعرف
يعني ما طال الزلزال اسطنبول ولكن وين
كانت اولويتك الولايات التركيه المدمره
ولا الشمال السوري
الصراحه كانت اولويتي هي اقرب مكان
بالنسبه الي يعني اقرب مكان واكثر مكان
فيني اوصل عليه بسرعه يعني لانه نحن وصلنا
على منطقه الزلزال بعد 24 ساعه من حدوثه
اذا بدي ادخل انا على الشمال السوري بعد
حدوث الزلزال فورا بدي استنى ازون يعني
لحتى ادخل بدي استنى تجهيز الشاحنه وكثير
امور واضطرقات مسكره يعني ما تنسي انه
الطرقات كلها مهدمه مسكره يعني حتى
الطرقات اثرت بالزلزال
فدرسنا ولقينا اقرب نقطه لنا مدينه
انطاكيا مع انه في مدن ثانيه تدمرت
بالزلزال لكن مدينه انطاكي ا بتحوي عدد من
السوريين جدا هائل
فحاولنا يعني نروح على المركز وهي المدينه
الصراحه كلها متدمره يعني مع الاسف ما بقي
فيها شيء مدينه بكاملها الفهد